so festlich kann mit den Füßen auf dem
Boden stehe so fest Träumen Menschen
schon seit 100 Jahren vom Fliegen schon
vor 500 Jahren hat sich Leonardo da
Vinci von Vögeln inspirieren lassen und
Entwürfe für verschiedene Fluggeräte
gezeichnet dutzende Erfinder haben über
die Jahrhunderte wilde Konstruktion
gebaut bis der deutsche Ingenieur Otto
Lilienthal 1891 zum ersten Mal mit
seinem selbstgebauten Gleiter geflogen
ist und die Gebrüder Wright 1903 das
erste richtige Flugzeug gebaut haben
dieses Video wird der Start einer langen
Reise bis ich irgendwann schaffen werde
selbst zu fliegen erst mit so einem
Gleiter Originalgröße und dann
irgendwann vielleicht sogar mit einem
selbstgebauten Flugzeug weil das aber
nicht nur super dumm klingt sondern ohne
Vorkenntnisse auch super dumm ist würde
ich das natürlich erstens nur in enger
Zusammenarbeit mit professionellen
Flugzeugbauer machen und mich zweitens
jahrelang darauf vorbereiten angefangen
mit dem heutigen Tag wo wir jetzt
erstmal klein anfangen mit einem
ferngesteuerten Flugzeug so eins habe
ich nämlich bis jetzt nicht nur noch nie
gebaut sondern ich bin auch noch nie
geflogen
dieses Video wird unterstützt von
Gänschen impact dort kann man ebenfalls
durch die Luft fliegen und zwar mit
wilden Gleitern wir wollen das Flugzeug
also so bauen dass man die normalen
Tragflächen hinterher durch unsere
nachgebauten Gänschen impact Gleiter
ersetzen kann und dann schauen wir ob
das Teil damit immer noch fliegt die
Form von unserem Flugzeug sollte ganz
grob so aussehen dass man hier so eine
Stange hat dann hier in der Mitte die
Tragflächen hinten das sogenannte
Leitwerk und vorne eben so ein Propeller
während der Gleiter von Otto Lilienthal
aus hanfsaal Baumwollgewebe Stahldraht
und Holz gebaut wurde und wie beim
ersten Flugzeug diesen Propeller einfach
aus Holz geschnitzt haben haben wir dann
ein paar moderne Sachen zur Auswahl für
diese Stange hier eben einmal Holz ganz
klassisch dann Aluminium und eben Carbon
und jetzt muss ich das mal raus das
Beste ist weil Holz klar ne Klassiker
auch noch relativ günstig aber wiegt
hier 11,6 Gramm das Aluminium sogar
deutlich mehr mit 24,2 und Carbon
einfach 13 Gramm also ungefähr so viel
wie das Holz ein Unterschied das Carbon
ist halt ul tra steifen ultra robust und
Holz
könnte ich alles aufbrechen wenn ich
wollen würde die Entscheidung ist also
leicht für die Tragflächen haben wir
zwei teststücke vorbereitet einmal aus
PLA also das ist das Material aus dem
wir quasi auf dem Kanal ja alles drucken
ist nachwachsende Rohstoff das Teil ist
gemacht aus Maisstärke und hier einmal
eins zu eins genau das gleiche Ding aus
Carbon verstärkten Pegg ist idealerweise
einmal leichter und noch stabiler CLA
wiegt hier 15 Gramm und zwar exakt und
das liegt hier
14,46 Gramm ist nicht so viel aber
ungefähr 5% leichter und wenn man sich
die einsparen kann dann nehmen wir das
doch jetzt muss Pascal eigentlich das
ganze nur noch eine Form bringen die
fliegt und das ist gar nicht so leicht
zum Glück gibt es kostenlose Programm um
solche Flieger zu konzentrieren in dem
Programm für dass ich mich entschieden
habe kann man das Flugzeug mit einem Art
Baukastensystem zusammenfliegen als
erstes zu sein ich die Gruppe Form dann
habe ich ewig nach dem perfekten
Querschnitt bzw Profil für die Flügel
gesucht um mich für 1 entschieden das
mit gnadenlos gutmütig für Anfänger
beschrieben wurde jetzt erstmal
simulieren ob das Flugzeug überhaupt
fliegen will und ja im richtigen Winkel
haben wir sogar tatsächlich auftreten
weil das aber natürlich noch kein
richtiges Flugzeug ist wird erstmal
mehrere Stunden drauflos konzentriert
das ganze hat bis hierhin gerade mal
drei Tage gedauert und das coole ist
dass wir noch nicht einmal wissen ob das
Ding später wirklich fliegen kann das
Modell hier das kommt jetzt noch
hinterher mal schauen
[Musik]
das große Ziel ist es mit dieser Reihe
früher oder später an den Punkt zu
kommen denn Apparat zu bauen mit dem ich
mich selbst irgendwie in der Luft halten
kann ähnlich und mit den Gleitern in
Gänschen impacts dem Sponser des
heutigen Videos wir waren unsere
Tragflächen hier extra so dass man
verschiedene Gleiter Designs drauf
anwenden kann genauso wie im Spiel wo
man nicht nur verschiedene Gleiter
nutzen kann um die riesige und schöne
Welt zu erkunden sondern auch unzählige
Charaktere mit einzigartigen Fähigkeiten
spielen kann bei Genthin im Text kommt
ständig neue charakterien hinzu denn
Angriffe verschiedene Elemente haben die
man kreativ kombinieren kann und Büro
Angriff direkt nach dem hydrohgriff 14
verdampfen und gibt dadurch extra
Schaden was das Kampfsystem super
spannend macht mit unseren Gleiter holen
wir uns ganz schön im päck ein Stück
weit ins echte Leben was ihr aber viel
einfacher haben könnt denn vom 29 bis 30
Juli gibt es in Berlin das Sommerfest in
komplettes Gänschen impact offline Event
mit Cosplay Minigames und einem
Bühnenprogramm das Event ist komplett
kostenlos ihr braucht keine
Eintrittskarten alles was ihr machen
müsst ist euch über den Link in der
Videobeschreibung anzumelden und nach
Berlin zu kommen ob wir mit diesem
wilden Gleiter in echt jetzt wirklich
fliegen können das sehen wir später
zuerst versuchen wir aber mit normalen
Parkflächen zu fliegen bauen also am
Flugzeug weiter und dafür brauchen wir
jetzt eine Befestigung für unseren
kleinen orangenen Motor aus Aluminium
meine Mutter immer viel zu heiß für
unseren 3D druckkunststoff wird so jetzt
wollen wir zusammen sind wir mehr geil
sind jetzt die ganzen Einzelteile hier
Propeller aluplättchen das Manor gemacht
hat dann den ganzen 3D Druck Part Flügel
Elektronik Bauteile Carbon Cube und die
pass auf warte das Leid
auf Rotor okay er hängt da drin
Propeller
und das ist voll crazy weil die stecken
hier einfach so auf diese Stange hier
drauf geht vorne kleine Schraube
ist so geil weil die Klappen sich
einfach nach hinten wie so ein Vogel
einfach aber wenn man die dreht sich
hoch
[Musik]
den Akku rein und jetzt halt einfach mal
so dass deine Finger dann am Ende am
besten kleben und vielleicht auch so
hoch dass er nicht den Tisch mitnimmt
Peter sich richtig gut
richtig
ja
[Musik]
die beiden Flügel wir haben jetzt hier
schon klappmechaniert wurde sehr geil
und die Kamera zusammenkleben ich mache
das gleich mal die kommen dann später
auf dieses Raster drauf so ein bisschen
Sekundenkleber
die andere Seite Aktivator
und das passt schon
es funktioniert in der füge mal jetzt
mal fest so und die wird tatsächlich
aber drauf gespannt an die Stelle ja
dass du nicht mehr zurückrutschen
man betet die ganze Zeit so dass es
fliegt und man weiß es halt nicht finde
das ganz am Ende raus aus funktioniert
echt ähm
spannendsten
diese beiden Schnüre eine davon jeweils
immer rein und die andere drückt immer
raus soll ganz gut wenn ich jetzt hier
runter geht dann zieht die obere rein
und wenn ich hier hoch gehe dann zieht
die untere rein deswegen bin ich jetzt
äh die Schnüre man diese Gelenke fest
[Musik]
geil geil oben
und unten
hey krass das funktioniert
geil okay
durch den Flügel
durchgelenkt und dann rein
Thomas wenn das jetzt direkt kaputt
machst ne
also es ist geil was bewegt sich alles
Thomas direkt wieder Gas aus bevor auf
dem Boden knallt ne ja ja
keine cabriolen
fast gar nicht richtig Rüdiger
mal starten
ich weiß gar nicht ob ich das machen
will jetzt noch mal so
[Musik]
dass ich schon selber in die Luft oder
ja ich glaube der wird schon der hat
schon Bock das ist nur noch wie geht das
ich weiß nicht ob ich anfangen soll
super halten
also eigentlich liegt ziemlich genau
kann es sich in der Luft halten das ist
relativ neutral vielleicht ein Ticken
schwerer noch aber vielleicht noch so 20
30 Gramm wo hast du nicht hinkriegt wie
würdest das angehen ich würde Vollgas
geben werfen
also was kann das jetzt fest zu
überzeugen dass es voll schlau ist total
jetzt einfach reinzuwerfen ins Feld und
zu hoffen dass es fliegt warte pass auf
also hier ist Gas hier hebe ich dann ab
und hier denke ich ja ja okay muss noch
Gas geben oder Alter ja wirf mal drei
zwei eins
ja okay wir gehen mal rein
ja okay okay bergungsmission 1A ist noch
besser als vorher okay
ich glaube der ist vorne einfach direkt
ins Zoll rein ja okay ja
[Gelächter]
hat sich gar nicht gut angehört
[Musik]
alle guten Dinge sind drei
aber voll gut
auch relativ human gelandet
also mit jedem Versuch ist halt einfach
ein Stück weit mehr Panzertape drauf
aber irgendwann wird der fliegen
[Musik]
geblieben also ich bin positiv
überrascht okay let's go Windows
[Musik]
wir gehen jetzt mal mit der Windrichtung
oha nächstes mal ein bisschen höher
ziehen so wie wir uns das Auftauen
funktioniert das Ganze jetzt überhaupt
nicht aber wir haben ja noch eine
Mission und zwar wollen wir wissen ob
wir den Gleiter aus Gänschen impact in
echt zum Fliegen bekommen drum haben wir
den kurzerhand in vier Stunden nach
modelliert und zwar noch mal deutlich
größer als die vorherigen Tragflächen
damit der mehr Auftrieb hat und
hoffentlich wirklich fliegt ab damit in
den 3D Drucker
[Musik]
ich mir den einmal und mal den an
hier habe ich ein Bild von den Flügeln
schauen wir mal das genauso hinkriegen
[Musik]
also eigentlich habe ich jetzt auf
diesen ganzen impact Alter ein bisschen
weniger auf dem Gesetz weil der nicht
ganz so irre dynamisch ist weil da
einfach coole Ornamente hat wir haben
den allerdings ein gutes Stück größer
gemacht sodass sie einfach deutlich mehr
Tragfläche hat und jetzt ist das noch
mal ein Ass im Ärmel vielleicht fliegt
ja boah ich muss ja jetzt über meinen
Kopf vorbei werfen weil nicht dass ich
dann einfach so zack okay warte wir
machen Flugzeug wir machen Funktionstest
Alter wir gehen richtig ab oder sind
perfekt jetzt ja
okay ja ich habe auch rechtzeitig einen
Propeller ausgemacht alles war schon
viel besser schon viel besser
nach oben ich glaube ich muss auch noch
vielleicht ein Stück stärker werfen und
der weiß richtig stabil
das hat laut getan also immer jemanden
bricht ja es ist schlimmer für mich ich
würde mal ohne Motor werfen ja weil es
ist ja ein Gleiter
oh das war eine dumme Idee okay der
fliegt ohne Motor überhaupt nicht gut
wir müssen also auf jeden Fall noch viel
lernen und erst mal in ferngesteuerten
Flieger zum Fliegen bringen bevor man an
selbst fliegen denken kann aber
irgendwann sehe ich mich mit so einem
Gleiter und dem Ziel sind wir heute ein
Stück näher gekommen ihr könnt aber
schon jetzt mit dem Geister die
zauberhafte Welt von Gänschen impact
entdecken mit dem neuen Patch der gerade
raus kam gibt's eine neue Region neue
Events Outfits und neue einzigartige
Charaktere lohnt sich also das
auszuprobieren und vielleicht bekommt er
dabei ja Inspiration für ein Cosplay mit
dem wir dann zwischen den 29 und 30 Juli
auf Sommerfest in Berlin geht aber das
geht natürlich auch ohne Cosplay alle
Infos zum kostenlosen Event findet ihr
in der Videobeschreibung ich bin damit
raus macht's gut